بوك الوضع اليوم اليس طبيعيا بل خطيرا
وحاسم هذا الوصف لقائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني حسين سلامي كشف عنه في محافظه قم
المركز الديني الشيعي الرئيسي في العالم
والمتحكمه مرجعياتها الدينيه في ايران
سلام يسمى الاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي تزامن
خطوبه مع دخولها الشهر الرابع بالفتنه
مكرران التحذيرا من ان الاوضاع ليست
اعتياديه بل خطيره ومصريه واستثنائيه
بالتزامن مع زياده العقوبات على ايران
سلام الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا
تحديدا في السعي لتدمير نظام طهران رغم ان
اكثر من تقرير المحلي حمل رجالات طهران
مسؤوليه انفجار الشارع في وجوههم في
الاحتجاجات غير المسبوقه وفق خبراء تجاوزت
المطالبه الى اهداف في بلد يحتوي اصحابه
منذ اربعه عقود بنيران الاجهزه الامنيه
التي تطارد اليوم جينا والشعر العيش بحريه
في شوارع ومدن ايران حنان المصري العربي